Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa.
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Yes.
Thank you, Ruffians, for joining us today for our 37th episode.
37!
Huh?
That's almost the whole human life.
37 years is almost a full spooky.
BAU BAU!
I don't really get it.
37 times 2.
Or 3.
Spooky.
3 if we do our best.
The humans do our best.
Yeah.
Ruffians.
I see a few Ruffians.
It might be the first FUWAMOCO Morning.
Maybe it's the first time you woke up early.
It's nice to meet you.
To explain about FUWAMOCO Morning, it's a short format morning show that is held every Friday to this Wednesday and Monday.
A.K.A FUWAMOCO!
Makes sense.
And it's hosted by us!
FUWAMOCO!
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag.
Hashtag.
FWMCMORNING.
It's not funny!
It's funny.
It's not.
I'm saying the hashtag.
Hashtag this.
Is it necessary though?
It is.
It's not a bit funny.
It is not funny.
Very serious.
Wow, let's ignore that.
And all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Oh, Ruffians.
Did you ignore it?
It's been a bit of a busy week.
Bit of a spooky week.
And you know, Halloween's just right around the corner.
But, I don't know, what's Pero off doing?
Oh, who knows?
Who cares?
Have you seen him?
I think one Ruffian saw him!
De-den.
It looks like this Ruffian came across some inspiration while they were busy carving pumpkins for Halloween.
It looks nice.
Right?
I think it turned out great.
What?
Pero didn't get in the way though, right?
Especially when you use all the sharp knives to cut the pumpkin.
You know, sometimes Pero can get a little bit mysterious.
A little bit mischievous and mysterious.
She's got knives and everything.
I'm glad it was okay though, but you know, yeah, you finished the pumpkin!
Yeah!
It looks amazing and I think all your fingers are still attached.
Hopefully!
I think the Ruffian would have let us know, right?
Maybe.
You know, you really got Pero's ears there and the wings and the horns too!
Actually, I think Pero kind of looks a bit proud of your pumpkin, you know?
A bit proud, yeah.
A bit smug.
It seems like it rubbed his ego just in the right spot by having his very own pumpkin.
Right.
Maybe he feels like it's sort of like a statue of him or like
It's a pumpkin.
It's just a pumpkin.
It's not a statue.
Well, you know, as long as Pero's in a good mood and he's not messing with you, I guess it's okay, right?
All's well that ends well, right?
We'd really like to see what the pumpkin looks like all lit up, too.
Oh yeah!
At night!
Have a happy Halloween!
Halloween!
BAU BAU!
Hello Halloween, BAU BAU!
I'm Ruffians!
On the topic of Halloween.
If you didn't know it, we have.
We're asking something of you.
We are.
Ruffians.
You're gonna join us for Halloween, right?
Right!
And we're gonna share some spooky stories together with you, right?
But not just any stories.
No!
Those stories will be written by you!
Yeah!
Well, I guess most of them, right?
Because maybe we'll write some too, but the spookiest part
You won't know if it was us or not, hai!
Which one is us, hai!
Well, you can submit your stories to us through our Google Form, which is in the description below.
Just look down a bit, okay?
Just look a little bit down.
But we'd like to ask you to write completely original stories that are around 250 to 1,000 words in length.
Don't worry if it's a bit over 1,000.
A bit under.
It's okay.
Yeah, we're not gonna take a grade off or anything.
No!
We're not your teacher.
But there's other things that we'd like you to be mindful of too.
That they don't contain any characters or properties from other IPs.
But hololive is okay, the original characters are good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And that they don't have any offensive content either.
Easy to team, okay?
But it also, it really really needs to be completely original, okay?
We want you Ruffians to have written it, not anyone else that defeats the point.
Defeats the point.
Yeah, but there could be like silly and spooky stories that actually happen to you too.
Or maybe ones that are just in your head.
But you know, anything that helps you get writing a little bit.
We're looking forward to sharing stories all together on a
Special first Halloween night together!
BAU BAU!
Well, Halloween stuff doesn't quite end there.
We have... In case you missed it... The Manor!
Ruffians!
Spooky stories, huh?
You had a chance to listen to our very first vocal dramas all together with Advent, right?
Yeah, the manners!
You haven't forgotten, right?
Yeah.
Yes, yes, good!
It's a spooky voice drama that us and Advent participated in as part of the Advent Halloween Party!
We weren't our usual FUWAMOCO self that you know us as, but we were two maid sisters!
Maria and Aria.
Not Cuban dog sisters!
No!
If you haven't had a chance to check it out yet, you can find it on the hololive store!
We'd love it if you could have a listen to it while it's still spooky to you.
Also, Advent has some extra spooky and cool t-shirts and apparel on sale right now as well.
You can find that over on Amazon!
Bit of a different place, but this time just search up hololive production to find them.
BAU BAU!
Halloween's gonna be over soon, but...
There's also something else very big coming up.
Very important!
You know what?
Right after Halloween is the yearly hololive Sports Festival!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
We're participating on the Red B Team!
Red Team!
And we're together with Aki-senpai, Mel-senpai, Aoi, Ina-senpai, and Calli-senpai!
We're very excited.
Very, very excited Ruffians!
I, Jimmy Kinaflames, you're excited for that, huh?
Well, I'm excited because it's gonna be fun!
And we're really happy to have this opportunity, but... It's also a bit nerve-wracking.
Yeah, we're nervous.
We're gonna do our best to make our senpai proud!
But we also hope that Lady Luck is on our side too.
Going to make sure to practice as much as we can!
To get a bit more used to Minecraft.
It'll also be our first sports day ever, so... Lots of firsts.
A lot of firsts, yeah.
Is there anything you think we should look out or know in particular, Ruffians?
Look out for... You know, like, oh, this senpai, this is a bit tricky for them.
I think it might be tricky for FUWAMOCO.
Or like, Minecraft is this.
Practice in front of the Ruffians.
Okay!
Are you sure you want that?
Don't use controller, but I don't think Minecraft works.
No, no controller.
You have to use keyboard.
Like, oh, that's not much we can do about that.
Out of our control.
Double W for dash.
Ah, yes, yes, yes!
I learned that the other day again!
Yeah!
I have to write down the controls.
I pray for no server issues.
I'll do that too.
Lots to look out for.
Well, we're going to do our best!
So please cheer for the red team lots and lots, okay?
And especially for us Minecraft newbies, okay?
Cheer for us, for FUWAMOCO, okay?
Let's bring victory to the red team!
Red team!
BAU BAU!
We should make a cheer.
We should.
Lots of things to prepare.
BAU BAU!
Ruffians!
Maybe we have something to confess.
A confession.
To confess about FUWAMOCO Morning!
I don't know if the Ruffians are gonna be happy to hear this.
Do you have any ideas what it could be?
No.
No?
Well...
It's not about how, you know, this is supposed to be a short format show.
Right.
And yet it always seems to be somewhere between 30 to 40 minutes.
It's not that.
Uh-uh, it's not that.
You know, it's not that, you know, we see Ruffians saying that it's hard to watch it all before school or work.
No.
It's not so short.
We're still working on it, I bet.
We're still working on that.
20 minutes, 20 minutes just to go on.
But, actually, at first, FUWAMOCO Morning, it was planned to be every single day of the work week.
Every weekday.
Everyone.
Can you imagine that?
How would you feel about that, Ruffians?
Every day of the work week.
The weekdays.
Right.
But you know what?
I don't know if we'd be able to survive that.
Yeah.
We definitely couldn't handle it alone.
But maybe there's a team.
A team like a FUWAMOCO Morning production team.
Yeah.
I don't know when we'd sleep.
It would be too much.
Ruffians, if it was daily, what do you think it would be like?
Would we have new corners?
Like a FUWAMOCO live sleep camera?
I don't think YouTube would be happy with that.
No, I don't think so.
Do you think we'd be able to wake up every day for it?
Maybe it's best that it's only three days a week?
I think so.
You want a live sleep camera?
Guests.
Guests and crew.
30 Minute Natto Challenge!
That's like natto prison for Moco-chan.
Do they sound more healthy?
I think so too.
I'm happy for the FUWAMOCO of the past.
Great choices were made.
Oh, that would be rough, right?
Ruffians.
Do you think you could deal with that?
It's great being every Friday, Wednesday, Monday, right?
FUWAMOCO.
Exactly.
Fits all to the timeline.
It's too much!
Well then, it's good that it's like this.
It's good!
Good for us!
Good for the Ruffians.
I'm glad, I'm glad.
I thought for sure the Ruffians would be like... We missed it!
Right?
It was good.
BAU BAU!
Now, this is very important, Ruffians.
Important?
It's very important!
That's true.
Maybe it's a bit of a misunderstanding.
I think, you know, there's something that's kind of stuck in the Ruffians' minds because it's a bit unpleasant.
Right?
And maybe it's become a bit of a misunderstanding too.
So, I mentioned it yesterday on Twitter, okay?
But you know, I saw some Ruffians trying to make Rat King tea.
But you aren't doing it properly!
And you know that's bad.
You're gonna hurt yourself and we don't want that.
Okay.
It's very important that the only thing that touches the teabag is hot water.
That's the first step, okay?
No, the teabags don't have to be moldy.
They won't get moldy if you do it properly, okay?
They don't touch anything except hot water.
So, no milk, no sugar, nothing.
Okay?
Nothing touches the teabag.
Just water.
Got it?
Now, next.
You have to squeeze it out after you're done with it.
Squeeze.
Yeah.
So you get all the tea back in the cup.
Okay, so then the teabag should be dry.
Got it!
You can't let it sit in a pool of tea.
Uh-uh.
It has to be dry.
You can't just put it on the dish, okay?
No.
It has to be dry.
Now, food!
Each tea bag!
They need to be spaced out on their own so they can properly dry.
Just so you know, I'm not giving you a tutorial, okay?
This is my rat king tea, okay?
Moco-chan's recipe, okay?
I just don't want you to hurt yourself!
They have to properly dry like that.
They can't be touching, okay?
And finally, they can't keep sitting there for too long.
I'd say.
Maybe a week maximum.
Maximum.
They don't mold.
I've never had issues with mold.
Not in the Northwest Passage.
They don't mold, okay?
But with that, the weak rule.
More than anything.
It's that I don't like having the used teabags sitting out from where I can see them.
That's the issue.
They just don't look very nice.
They don't look nice, no.
But this way, I've never had issues with mold.
My tummy's never hurt.
Nothing.
It's good.
Okay.
It's just resourceful to get another teacup out of the teabags.
Got it.
Write that down.
Don't write that down.
It's not a tutorial.
Just don't hurt yourself.
Good kids don't copy Moco-chan, right?
You're not gonna hurt yourself, right?
No sugar.
No milk.
Okay.
You do that after.
After.
Understood.
Good, good.
It's not a tutorial!
Not a tutorial!
Just buy more tea bags.
Easier said than done.
Do you understand Ruffians?
Do you still have a problem with Moco-chan's habits?
My tummy hurts when it's scary, okay?
Not because of the rat king tea, right?
Yes!
No, not really.
It's good to be honest.
If it makes her happy, dot dot dot.
It's just resourceful, okay?
I won't try it, but got it.
That's the spirit!
Alright.
Just understand, okay?
I don't know if the Ruffians quite understand it yet, Moco-chan, but... It's time for Mococo to stop.
Stop?
Stop, Moco-chan?
Big sigh.
Not Mococo.
No.
Better stop.
Please stop.
Dot, dot, dot.
What, lapero thing?
I don't care about lapero things!
It seems like the Ruffians accept it.
Moco-chan.
Oh, you're a different size.
Wait.
You'll accept Moco-chan even if she drinks the Rat King tea!
Thank you!
BAU BAU!
That's happy, right Moco-chan?
What?
We're Ruffians!
We do!
Ruffians... Well... You know...
Dad!
Guess what?
He picks the lightbulb!
We have light!
We live in a world with den now!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Yeah, it's so nice.
You know, especially when the days just keep on getting darker and colder.
We have light now.
Actually, it's why it's so cold so quickly.
We thought that we left the air conditioning on by accident, but...
This is the start of a new reality.
Maybe... Maybe it's time to start eating more yummy food so we can get fluffy and fuzzy for the winter!
Soup.
We already eat soup.
I don't know if getting fluffier and fuzzier is a proper solution, Moco-chan, you know?
Instead of like more insulation for our bodies, you know?
It's gonna take some time to kind of get rid of in the spring.
We can just put on sweaters, you know?
Sweaters or fluffy pajamas and ride.
But what if I wanna eat?
Stew.
Stew?
How is soup and stew different that much?
Stew's expensive, soup is cheap.
I guess.
Stew is stew.
What?
That's what I was called.
Stew is stew!
No!
Stew is a stew, right?
And a soup.
Soup.
It's like it's a stoop and soup.
Hi.
Ruffians, you get it right.
I don't think I get your brain.
Soup and stew and soup and stoop.
Right?
They're similar but different.
I think it's time for you to go back to bed.
Well, happy news!
Happy news!
We have a light!
Yeah!
BAU BAU!
Enough with the silliness.
Maybe we'll check out some of our regular costumes here.
The Doggie of the Day is... Dan Lily!
She's super cute, look at all that.
What kind of Halloween costume do you think this is though?
A lion?
A monster?
An SSR?
Makusou?
Version of... Really?
Definitely that.
It's cute though!
It makes me want to fluff her up.
She has crazy hair!
Right?
Cute!
I was thinking, how does she BAU BAU?
You know, I think it would have to match the costume, right?
Like an SSR BAU BAU.
I think it would be still sort of rough.
BAU BAU it!
BAU BAU!
Why does it have the power?
SSR, Moco-chan.
Oh, SSR power?
Yeah.
What's that?
BAU BAU!
Like that.
I think that's fair.
Right?
Like, when Pokemon, when they evolve, they're, they're, they're cool?
They kind of get all weird, right?
Before it's like, wee-dee-weep!
And then it's like, BAU BAU!
Right?
I guess, right?
Uh-huh, makes sense.
Uh-huh.
Well, I think Lily really enjoys Halloween with you.
There's lots of fun things going on, and new people to meet, and even more fun costumes.
For one day a year, she gets to become a little bit of a different, a different kind of Lucia, a different side of herself.
Lucia, she loves you very much.
BAU BAU!
Even though it's getting cold in, we're still going out, right?
Let's see where you went!
I'm excited.
The walks have been very pretty.
It's a pinky.
The colors!
It's a painting.
You know, I feel like I have every color I need to paint a beautiful picture, right?
I feel like I need to add nature sounds in the corner, right?
Howl!
A new alarm!
A dentist!
No!
These are furry sounds, okay?
What is furry?
A robot!
No!
I don't know.
Maybe we didn't quite get it, Moco-chan.
Maybe not.
Oh, but I can definitely tell why this would be your favorite song.
Yeah!
Maybe next time you go, you can let out a big BAU BAU for us.
Maybe it will echo.
Oh.
BAU BAU!
Like that.
BAU!
BAU BAU!
So many colors.
I'm not envious.
Uh-uh.
Right?
Nope.
We got a question from a Ruffian too.
Our Question of the Day is...
Hi FUWAMOCO!
Is there any specific food that instantly teleports you back to your childhood when you eat it?
For me, it's the pasta salad that my mom always used to make for dinner.
Love you!
Screams!
BAU BAU!
I don't know, it's not really a food.
But, I wanted to eat it, but I don't think they make it anymore.
For some reason, I really- Hi.
I really remember, uh, these sort of cloth drops.
They were black liquid, and they came in a roll.
And they were called, I think, beach knots.
Right?
And the paper was like a wax paper?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It was fun to unwrap them.
Beach knots.
But it came in a roll, they were all connected.
They were cloth drops.
Does that make sense?
I don't think so, but... I don't know if that's really a food, but I would like to have that.
For me... It's not a food either, but I feel like... Moco-chan, I don't... I'm pretty sure you probably had the same one, too.
Because if we get ice cream, you always pick the same thing as me, too, right?
That's just how it goes, right?
But there was one time...
It was flat.
But it was round.
And it tasted like the most orange you could ever imagine.
I can remember it so much.
Just thinking of it makes my mouth kind of water a bit.
But I only ever had it that once.
I don't know what you're talking about.
An orange popsicle.
It was shiny!
How does it remind you of your childhood if you had it once?
Because it reminded me of eating it that once.
Why the taste of the color orange?
Exactly!
It tasted so orange!
So orange!
I don't know, you could just eat an orange.
No, it was better than that.
It was like pure, pure orange.
It was good.
Fuwawa's core memory?
It is!
I only had it once and I remember it.
Other than that, no like, cough drops and popsicles aren't food.
I guess I remember the many, many carrot sticks we had to eat.
Yeah.
And sometimes, you know, eating carrot sticks multiple times a day.
It's a lot of carrots.
So they kind of get boiled and you think, what can I do to make this interesting?
So then you take some yellow mustard and you eat it with the carrot and it actually tastes kind of good.
Moco-chan, why are you shaking your head?
You did it too!
Yes, but I don't like the memory.
Ruffians, did you ever do that?
Same!
Yes.
We have to eat it.
Otherwise there's no escape.
There's no escape.
You have to eat it.
Why not ranch?
No ranch.
No stuff like that.
Yellow mustard.
I don't like this.
I'll go without that.
Thank you.
I hope your pasta salad was yummy.
Yummier than that.
And carrots with mustard.
I also remember being forced to eat some rice.
Rice that I didn't like.
I remember falling asleep at the table at night.
I do too.
We're very picky eaters.
There's a lot of times when we're imprisoned at the table.
We're used to being imprisoned.
BAU BAU!
We have no time for sleeping!
It's FUWAMOCO Morning!
And we have more streams coming in!
Our next stream tonight is a bit spooky, so don't be surprised, okay?
Get ready, okay, Ruffians?
You can blur your eyes, okay?
Blur them, okay.
Just look into my eyes.
Okay, it's not scary.
Tonight, we're going to be playing DRAWL.
I'm trying to make it funny because it's scary.
We're worried, Ruffians.
Please, please, please come help us.
I don't know if Advent can do this.
I talked about it yesterday during our member stream, but I have not bought that game.
I have not downloaded the game.
I need to do that, but it is frightening.
So I need strength.
Yeah, especially after Paranormal Cleanup last time.
It's not that scary!
Our confidence is very strong.
I don't know, Ruffians.
You've been watching our streams this month, right?
I think our confidence is sort of a bit gone, huh?
A bit depleted.
Yeah.
You're shaking already?
Why?
It's too scary.
Wait, Ruffians.
Controller isn't supported, right?
It's not supported.
It's a keyboard and mouse kind of thing, right?
Please say so.
We'll see.
I-I hope it's a keyboard and mouse kind of thing because... then... I just need to help.
I just need to help.
You don't recommend controller.
Okay!
It has controller support.
I've never touching anything.
Well.
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU
BAU BAU!
Well, we're playing Suica Game in the morning, so if you wake up early with us, then that means you get to find out the schedule for next week earlier, and we hope that you're very much ready because it's a jam-packed week with fun coming up, so... BAU BAU!
Really busy, but very exciting too!
Do we have some tricks?
We do have some tricks and treats!
Some treats!
Please look forward to the Ruffians!
Thank you so much for joining us today for
37th episode of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Ikiasura!
BAU BAU!
Adric!
Dudamesh!
BAU BAU!
Brandon!
Odessie!
BAU BAU!
Bolt.
Leaf the Beef.
BAU BAU!
Ulyss.
Belly Boy.
BAU BAU!
We've been BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
BAU BAU!
BAU!